l'opération a duré 30 heures 30 heure de
chirurgie pour effectuer une greffe
exceptionnel une greffe du visage une
première canadienne en janvier 2011
maurice dont on ne peut dévoiler le nom
de famille est victime d'un accident de
chasse
magri 4 chirurgie de reconstruction
rien n'y fait maurice est défigurée et
ils souffrent physiquement en 2014
le docteur daniel baur ce qui lui fait
une incroyable proposition une greffe du
visage et lorsqu'il vous a proposé
l'opération comment vous avez réagi lui
du roi du genre à long terme il faut
qu'on travaille dans la caboche comme un
dieu parce qu'ils ont donné un espoir de
nouvelles vies parce que l'espoir d'une
nouvelle vie l'eau on avoue ne répond
pas si c'est pas trop tôt
la proposition du docteur ne se limite
pas qu'à la peau mais à l'ensemble du
visage
on parle ici du nez et son cartilage des
os de la mâchoire d'aida et de la bouche
[Musique]
le tout dans un seul et même greffons je
sais tous les sujets qui vous ferai pour
toi aujourd'hui un petit souci pour toi
ok mon nom tout le monde lui convient
aujourd'hui de la gag bercy le bloc
opératoire est fin prêt on pratique la
toute première décision
le taux de succès si ces passants pour
ça il ya des risques très très très
graves qui sont associés avec ces gens
de chirurgie en a eu une longue
discussion mois lui sa phase
pendant qu'on retire le visage de
maurice lecorps du donneur arrive
les deux opérations sont effectuées en
parallèle neuf chirurgiens des
anesthésistes et une horde d'infirmières
et d'infirmiers forment l'équipe
médicale de toutes les crèmes
celle qui ne quittera jamais leur esprit
le risque de rejet c'est sûr que dans la
greffe de visage le rejet est très
présent c'est une menace qui est très
probable chez lui il s'expose à des
rejets on s'attend à ce qu'il ya un
rejet à un moment donné dans l'évolution
j'ai pas j'ai bien peur qu'il reste un
lot ils vivaient
mais si chaud ça fonctionne position
visage ça pour rejette le visage vont
faire quoi ça va fonctionner du peuple
ont bu il n'y a pas de plan b
mais est ce que vous avez peur d'échouer
malgré tout toujours il ya des choses
qu'on peut faire si jamais mais il
n'aime pas mais il n'y a pas de raison
que ça n'a pas marché
après 11 heures de chirurgie le retrait
du visage du donneur pratiquement
complétée
45 minutes plus tard la scène est
surréaliste pour mes toiles greffons
le futur visage de maurice il faut faire
vite on doit rebrancher les veines et
les artères le visage doit être irrigué
sans quoi c'est la nécrose
l'opération s'achève au total elle aura
duré 30 heures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
son transfert maurice aux soins
intensifs les prochaines heures seront
cruciales de toi
au cours des prochains jours maurice
sera maintenue dans un profond coma
on veut éviter qu'ils ne souffrent
inutilement dévoilé sa nouvelle identité
ce moment mort et c'est son chirurgien
l'attendait depuis très longtemps on
s'affaire
c'est tout à fait
le pape a joué et est intense
[Musique]
la médecine progresse à petits pas une
marche souvent parsemée d'échecs les
parfois d'incroyables succès mais
derrière tout avancer on retrouve
l'audace de médecins aient le courage de
son patient est un document vraiment
fascinant et vraiment c'est renversant
en fait on a donc découvert le nouveau
visage de maurice commence porte-t-il et
puis comment est ce qu'ils se trouvent
la toute première victoire c'est qu'il
ne souffre plus donc ça c'est quelque
chose de très important et on lui a posé
la question est ce que la nouvelle
apparence te plaît et il se trouve très
beau donc c'est vraiment exceptionnel de
voir à quel point cet homme là est un
survivant parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
problèmes liées justement sa figure donc
il se porte bien il n'a pas encore
recouvré l'usagé de sa mâchoire donc il
ne peut pas parler pour lui c'est très
difficile il ne peut pas encore mangé
dont qui a perdu beaucoup de poids parce
qu'il y avait mais somme toute là ça va
bien et tout ça était prévu on sait que
ça va prendre encore six mois peut-être
même un avant qu'ils puissent couvrir
usage de sa mâchoire et donc de pouvoir
parler mais c'est quand même juste une
étape où il ya beaucoup de défis de
grand défi qui l'attend mais le premier
défi si les risques de rejet
si on regarde la littérature on sait
qu'il va voir présence de rejet à un
moment donné ou à un autre tout le monde
est avisé lui-même le sait donc la prise
de médicaments sera très très important
et essentiel c'est essentiel le risque
donc pour éviter donc leur rejet on
utilise des médicaments anti rejet qui
affaiblissent le système immunitaire de
sorte qu'il peut être victime d'une
toute petite bactérie qui pour nous pour
vous et moi serait absolument pas
dangereuse mais dans son cas parce
qu'ils ont un système immunitaire très
bas le risque est très grand donc
jusqu'à présent ça va bien mais il ya
encore de nombreux défis devant lui
alors c'est vraiment un exploit
scientifique mais c'est pas seulement un
exploit scientifique qui avait tout une
aventure humaine qu'est ce que vous
regardez c'est le bon mot c'est
carrément une aventure pour tout le
monde qui était présent on rapidement
pendant l'opération s'est rendu compte
que ça dépasse l opération chirurgicale
c'était vraiment une opération spirituel
il s'est passé quelque chose vraiment
incroyable pour tout le monde pour nous
ma collègue geneviève turcotte à la
réalisation on était vraiment marqué par
ce reportage
alors demain vous allez nous parler du
chirurgien du médecin vous allez nous
présenter un portrait et votre reportage
complet ça reportage d'une heure wind
vraiment à voir il sera dédié à
découverte le dimanche de 8h30 et sur
ici explora à 22h absolument merci
beaucoup la nuit gentil